Earlier I said there are many points of view on semantic interoperability.
Lloyd McKenzie is an internationally recognized expert
in HL7 data modeling and design and an adviser to Canada Health Infoway,
an organization with roughly the same role that the ONC plays here in the US.
In March 2013, he posted this on Graeme Greaves blog,
"Really robust semantic interoperability is going to be dependent on machine learning and
other technologies that will allow the computer to be at least as
good at reasoning and inferring context as humans are now.
At which point we won't need discrete data at all.
Computers will be able to take a big blob of text, dictation,
images and so on and extract all the relevant information
needed for their functions without it being neatly divided up for them."
I believe this is an important point of view.
Later, we will talk more about the potential for machine learning in healthcare.
For now, it is worth noting that the explosion in the use of this technology
was in large part due to the availability of huge digital data sets on the internet.
After all, the learning part of machine learning comes about when
computers process a huge number of examples of something.
This might be pictures of cats.
It might be examples of some text translated into another language.
It also might be EHR notes about rheumatoid arthritis.
Those first two data sets have been widely
available for some time now because of the Internet.
To be fair, they are also quite a bit more consistent than EHR notes.
Finally, of course, there are no privacy laws covering
cat photos or openly available translations of text.
Nevertheless, with EHR adoption now widespread and assuming we can
solve the easier levels of interoperability and have broader access to clinical data,
might semantic interoperability be best left to machines to figure out?